so I've had a really really busy week
and the problem is that's that's my
fault I've got no one to blame but
myself for being so busy and just having
so much on my mind and as I mentioned in
the last video of this kind of dev vlog
series thing I want each video to have a
particular theme I think that it's a
good chance for me to like answer a
question from the community or talk
about something you guys to get the
point and so what I've done is I've kind
of taken my thoughts wrap them into like
some ball and now I'm going to try and
push that ball into you guys okay so
what was so hard about this week why
what did I do this week hazel is getting
to the point where it's it's getting
kind of big and the problem isn't the
fact that it's getting big I've worked
with plenty of large game engines before
it's more so the fact that I want to do
everything there are so many things that
I want to do there are just want to have
a billion features done immediately like
today I want this engine to just be done
today but unfortunately that's not how
things work
that's not how software engineering
works that's not how that's not how
anything works and I think that it's
ultimately a really good reminder to
just take it slow because I know that a
lot of you are extremely ambitious
people you can it's very easy to get
into a phase where you just so you just
look passionate about something you know
nothing else matters you just want to
get it done you just don't care I mean I
wouldn't say nothing else matters but
the problem is you can't do it all you
have to realize that if you are a solo
developer even a small team working on a
particular project you're not going to
be able to do it all and that's a really
tough thing to hear I think for a lot of
people this is the same reason why we
have the whole MMORPG kind of meme of
just like new game developers
to make extremely ambitious like MMORPG
projects that usually take teams of
hundreds of people several years but
they just they're gonna do it man
because they're gonna keep working out
if they're really passionate about it
and then what happens a few months or
years later they realized that they just
have a nervous breakdown
and don't get me wrong I'm definitely
not having a nervous breakdown yet but I
do want to say that I think it's an
extremely important skill to be able to
pace yourself to be able to think
critically and to be able to just relax
a little bit and say that I will get
there eventually
because if you go if you go full force
into something with just like a reckless
kind of you know just reckless attitude
like not it's gonna be great I'm gonna
do all of it you're gonna end up
stressed out you're gonna end up burnt
out and in the end it's not gonna be
anything to show anyone so I think
ultimately this is an important lesson
for me it's an important lesson for you
it's an important lesson for a lot of
people to just relax take a break and
just consistently work it's a lot better
to be consistent than it is to go really
hard at something and then burn out so
instead of overworking and trying to do
everything at once
just relax take a step back and remind
yourself that you'll get that because I
believe in you okay all seriousness and
motivational speaking aside the reason
why I had such a busy week was because I
wanted to do a lot of things in hazel I
as I mentioned it's getting to the point
where there's just so many different
directions I want to take there's so
many things so many large pages that
need to get implemented I need to get
done and I basically spent the week
tackling two of them at once which was
an empty component system as well as a
scripting language and just general
scripting support the reason I wanted to
do those two things at once is not just
because they need to get done but
because they are kind of tied in
together like a scripting language and a
scripting interface I'll say is very not
it's not very useful unless you have an
etiquette
because the scripts that you write
should be interacting with the
components of entities and with entities
and with the scene and if now that
exists then like what are you doing are
you just binding your C++ API to your
scripting language so that you can write
a 3d renderer in like Lua or something
that doesn't really make sense if you
look at other game engines usually a
scripting language interfaces with
entities scenes and components and the
funny thing is that's kind of it you
don't need to expose you know render a
beginning scene to your scripting
language I mean you can and that might
be useful but you don't have to that's
not really the traditional route because
most people are just going to want to
manipulate this kind of entity component
system that is inside your game engine I
like to think of scripting as just
really being a puppeteer with like you
know puppet strings and you're
manipulating a puppet you're not really
supposed to be able to like write
everything that involves your game
engine inside the script you're really
just supposed to be pulling different
strings that do different things that's
kind of the point and that's a good way
to think about it because that way
you're not going to lose a lot of
performance by trying to do too many
things inside your scripting language
now don't get me wrong though sometimes
it's actually faster to do things inside
description language rather than do the
whole transition into C++ and then back
again and all that potential data
marshalling that you might have to do
but as a general rule you know it's
really important to define what belongs
in your runtime in your co-host runtime
and what belongs in your actual
scripting language and there is a lot I
could say about scripting languages
maybe I'll just save that for another
video but ultimately this all began with
me not being able to decide what
scripting language I wanted on one hand
I was fairly set on the fact that I
would use lower because Lua is extremely
fast if you use a jitter to kind of
version of lower like legit something
that is not interpreted at runtime it's
extremely fast it's probably the fastest
thing or one of the fastest things out
there there's really not much that can
beat it however the main reason that it
is so fast is because
it's so simple it's so kind of limited
the language is extremely
straightforward the actual syntax and
what you can do with the language in
terms of language features leaves a lot
to be desired as does the core library
there's a lot of issues with Laura it is
fantastic to script small kind of things
it's really good at that and to be
honest like you know I have nothing
against law in that regard but the
problem is the way that I see hazel is
first and foremost a game engine that I
am making to eventually make a game with
and not just like a little flappy bird
clone but like you know a big game and
do I want to write my game in Lua again
if it's like flappy bird then yeah sure
why not but if it's a big game I don't
think I do
and obviously like realistically if
you're working on a really big game and
hazel you probably want to use a lot of
C++ and that's to be expected but
ultimately I just don't see myself I
just don't see myself writing a large
game in Lua and I want to be able to
give people the opportunity to actually
write a large game in hazel without
touching in C++ so then I looks at
Python and Python you know I
pythons fine it's it's obviously a much
more like feature complete I'll say no
it's a language with a lot more features
than Lua it's got a fantastic library a
lot of people use it that C++ kind of
bindings are very good as well the C
bindings are very good everything is if
everything is great in Python I'm not a
huge fan of like the syntax or anything
because I'm also I'm used to like C++
and C style languages but it's it's fine
except that it's slow though and you
know performance for a game engine it's
like very important so by the way just
three with me so far I basically built a
little sandbox environment and test it
out like binding like various like
functions resources reference counting
all of that stuff between C++ and all of
these scripting languages I literally
built like a sandbox environment for
each of them and tested them for the
purposes of a game engine I didn't want
to integrate them into
straight away because I knew that would
take a lot of time but I did set up like
a pretty thorough kind of test case to
see what they would be like if I had
actually implemented them and then
finally finally the language I looked at
last was C sharp and C sharp is by far
my favorite language out of these three
but the reason I was sort of kind of
hesitant to jump into it straight aways
because I know it's fairly heavyweight
and I know that mano has very
restrictive licensing except for the
fact that that last part isn't true
anymore back when I look to C sharp last
seriously was probably for like Sparky
which is the novel game engine that I
had and I knew that like mono had
serious kind of restrictions back then
it was very difficult to actually build
mono like yourself build the binaries
yourself on whatever platform you're
going for you had to go through like you
had to ask them for licenses you had to
ask them for binaries I'm pretty sure
like it was like it was it was difficult
the licensing was very restrictive they
didn't want everyone using it to
everything since then though I think
Microsoft had like acquired them I might
be wrong correct me in the comments
below if I am but um Microsoft was
something acquired them or at least I
working with them so you know they're
working together and now it's just like
yeah man do we do whatever you want with
monitors as long as you you know pay
attention to these kind of rules but
like it's it's very open it's very very
accessible now and that's amazing and so
I'm like okay well I might as well try
this out what's the hum and Dad and I
did try it out and it was very easy and
it was very straightforward and all the
code you can build yourself and it's C
sharp C sharp is my favorite language
aside from C++ C was probably my my
favorite favorite language and the C
sharp is probably this my second
favorite language I haven't exactly used
C sharp extensively to write games I
mean I've obviously done some things
here and there using unity and I know C
sharp very well because back at EA we
used it for like all of our
windows-based tools which includes like
you know all the tools including a level
editor on like one of the engines I
worked at frostbites a frost ed let all
that editor's stuff is written in
c-sharp using WPF so I have a lot of
c-sharp experience because I was I was
mostly like a generalist of EA which
means that I basically did everything
and obviously a lot of game engine too
is the tools so I'm very familiar with
c-sharp I know a lot about its amazing
features amazing library it's a great
language and so that's what I did this
week I just slapped it into hazel the
first thing I did was actually put it
into hazel the public version like that
the public kind of hazel Trudy pushes
the game edge in the series the reason I
put it into that is because that's
obviously a smaller code base than hazel
dev which is with the 3d version of
hazel and I just thought that you know
let's start there so I basically looked
at various ECS systems oh we haven't
even talked about entity component
systems at all this video is dragging
out for so long
if you guys want to see more of this let
me know maybe I'll make more than one
with these videos a week or something
because I'm barely scratching the
surface of this telling you is a very
busy week long story short I jammed in
c-sharp into the public version of hazel
tested that that kind of worked I
started integrating a little bit of the
API and then I realized why am I doing
this I should just put this into hazel
dev because that's ultimately like where
I want to consolidate everything I want
to have one massive big codebase and
then that is what eventually I will
write the game engine series videos and
like the public version of hazel to
become so I moved all that in truth
hazel dev I integrated an entity
component system called ant en TT and
again lots to say about that but
probably set that for another video
and so now hazel dev has an NC component
system a scene system and c-sharp
scripting support I mean I haven't done
a lot of the API kind of bindings yet so
the c-sharp API is extremely limited but
check it out so while this might look
pretty much the same as last time maybe
a few few differences here and there
just with materials and all of that I
assure you that there has been a whole
lot of stuff that has happened under the
hood so this same hierarchy panel used
to just have like basically some dummy
data showing the single entity that we
had in the scene and then like the sub
meshes attached to the main mesh that
made up the entity and the entity really
just had like a ref to a mesh and it was
all kind of you know like the entity
class literally just had like a mesh the
material a transform all of that stuff
it was completely not an ACS now since
we're using ants under the hood which is
an AC
an anti component system these are all
actually entities if we click on one of
these entities like so you can see that
we have this properties panel here at
the lights up the properties panel shows
all of the components that this entity
has so you can see that this entity that
I've selected here is called test entity
it has a transform a mesh component and
a scripting partner but it also has a
tag component that's what this is and I
can easily rename this to like scene or
something like that now the plan is of
course to have like children and parents
and like an actual hierarchy here and
then you could expand them by just kind
of hitting this arrow here but we don't
support that yet so there's nothing
there to see and yeah that's kind of the
first major like thing here we have an
actual camera which has like a camera
component and that's what gets picked up
by the same class that's what you're
seeing here this view is the result of
an actual camera component I don't think
it really interacts with the transform
at all but the camera component is what
contains the actual camera and this
unnamed entity I think is just a test of
an empty entity this scene and see which
is in fact this kind of you know the
main thing that I can move around here
you can see that as I move it I can see
the translation here I can also scale it
up and down and I can see the scale
changing it's got a mesh component which
at the moment I'm just displaying the
file path to that mesh and then finally
you can see that we have this script
component and the script component has a
module named example to script and that
is because if I use the arrow keys here
you can see that I'm actually moving
this entire scene and that's because
surprised we have an on update function
inside our example script which is what
we saw there inside the script component
view and that is what is controlling
this movement I'll let you guys in on a
little secret actually didn't go
anywhere I'm actually going to record
the outro like straight after the first
part of the video and then record the
computer screen like later yeah so
little trick as I mentioned extremely
busy we've got all that stuff done I
haven't even shown you guys the
beginning of all this I'm super excited
to see where all this is going I'm just
super excited to implement all of this
to be honest there's so many things in
my head so many things I want to do and
just not enough time so that's a very
good state to be and just have to
remember
to relax and take it slow and not
rushing into all these things thank you
guys for watching if you enjoyed this
video please hit the like button you can
also help support hazel and all of the
videos and everything I'm doing here on
YouTube by going to patron accomplice -
the churner
I am live-streaming the development of
hazel dev weekly for Cait Ron's so if
you guys are interested and definitely
check that out huge thank you to all of
you for all of your amazing support the
only reason why hazel has come this far
I will see you next time good bye
[Music]
[Music]